I don't you know because I'm such a
purveyor of psychedelics people are
forever leaning on me to trip with them
and I dare say you know there are people
in this room who've known me for years
and no one here can say they've ever
been seriously loaded with me because I
just don't do it I can't take it I can't
handle the feeling the feeling of risk
that permeates that that's why it amazes
me I'm fascinated by people who have
such faith in their knowledge that that
apparent difficult situations don't
freak them out as an example some of you
know Frank Barr
he's an emergency room doctor and I'm
amazed that he can deal with people who
are dead out unconscious and just say
she'll come to in 40 minutes or so don't
worry about that when I would be frantic
I mean if I can't get a reaction out of
somebody I just go berserk and the
notion yeah I don't know whether that's
a kind of callousness therapists are
like that I mean they say you know you
come upon somebody flopping around on
the floor screaming pleading weeping my
inclination is to make them feel better
for God's sake and a therapist would
just say well they're working through
their down that's all right you know how
do you get that level of self confidence
where you can see somebody in agony and
say that's alright the best thing for a
check on them in an hour and to see
where they're at it's awfully so I stay
away from and in my own situation
I keep people away from me I've had many
trips where I fought in the middle of it
saying god there's no one here to see
this because if there were someone here
to see it
they would become alarmed and decide
that some crisis was in progress
and you know ultimately you have to sort
of get a kind of perspective where you
just say if I die I die but it usually
has to slam you into the wall pretty
severely to make you turn the image I
have is that I run from it until I
become so furious at this humiliating
situation that I turn and face it and
then you know if you curse it it will
step back sometime and it's worked every
time the other thing is you know the
wonderful instinct for equilibrium that
the human mind has that you can get
pretty twisted around and if you'll wait
24 hours 72 hours 10 days six months it
will restore to equilibrium I'm puzzled
by the cases of permanent raving madness
and I wonder how common they are it's
all messed up in this society I mean I
can show you psychiatric residents who
have never seen an unmedicated
schizophrenic in their entire life you
know because you just they just do not
encounter people in that state what they
deal with are people who come in and
given drugs and kept on drugs and drugs
drugs drugs that's the whole the whole
dynamic